[Applaudissements]
personne marc tu connais un petit peu
les équipes loba très près de toi non
non non
[Rires]
géraldine m'a dit tu aimes bien tu
devrais je dors [ __ ] les philosophes
moyen orient que ça m'excite
jean michel maire
non monsieur le maire te connais nous
fout je regarde le livre la porte c'est
une bibliothèque qui disent qu'ils
aiment oui toi tu prends tu te carpeaux
chez toi nicolas rey les plus humanistes
et non celui d'offrir ce truc moche dans
son jeu ken scott sharp antisémite glace
si tu as une meuf pas appel amadeus nabi
bush voulait c'est qu'ils n'ont rien à
voir à nouveau des lions pas bon délire
mais tout terrain
webb a lui aussi tout est refait surtout
les cheveux un genre je te connais tu
l'as bien sûr monsieur mahaman un clic
du poids la haye et tu sais qui pourrait
donner des conseils sur les meufs lui
ouais bah tron concept de données mais
calme gentil peut-être de s'épiler un
peu parce que là c'est la mode et plus
tellement
si moi je veux la sacu cei amouroux et
mais tellement drôle que je pense que
déjà le plus gros est fait avec les
filles qu'est ce qu'il ya il est
tellement drôle qu avec les filles je
pense que c'est gagné d'avancé et jean
michel maire soit elle meurt il nous a
fait une phrase là qu'on aurait pu avoir
sur france 3 à 16 heures à écouter les
cadres ont pris part aux actrices non
et génolhac symbian et couleurs de noël
oui je suis ressorti à la guirlande
dirais surtout à marron glacé à quoi
mais c'est vrai alors c'est du rêve lui
à j'aime bien je comprends rien mon truc
quand il est amené les jeunes on prend
comme nous je vais te dirai à est lui
aussi cherche une meuf
il est et qu'il était sûr qu'élire
moment le projet sur le programme sur le
projet gagnant était sur kelly après
l'été sur haga est en fait il est sûr
que l'on lui
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je n'ai aucune excuse vient pas le vôtre
si vous êtes maintenant voilà son calme
toi et thomas ce n'est qu'un petit jeu
calme-toi offriront à bala
un truc à dire sur banshee ni les ait
appris tout en dentelle tout à l'heure
dans les coulisses alors finalement je
vous dois dû balle ouais bah je vais
vous les donner je vous fait crédit
illimité d'accord merci bas ça me fait
ça me fais pas ça me fait extrêmement
vous l'avait bien dit jamais assez des
vrais amis en 50 et là je serai pas
toujours vrai isabelle morini bosc
là on se connaît depuis longtemps avec
isabelle c'est vrai vous nous indiquez
n'ont même pas vous connaissez on s'est
rencontré il ya longtemps j'ai fait mes
premières san devant ils avaient moins
de 180 2 wii et 42 ans dans un paysage
c'est vrai mais oui j'ai présidé à ses
débuts en partie ah ouais quand même
mais pourquoi partie des gens qui ont
cru à regagner des concours grâce à
isabelle non bon ça y est un jury où
j'étais à wells avec elle a lancé plein
de comics un raid dans le mur
on arrive à nos textes
roland brasse voilà une mésaventure sur
ce même plateau 1 voilà mais ça va
s'arranger on pense
ouais à côté c'est qu'il ya ni que
l'ambiance un ouais
et puis à côté c'est que d'un côté
bernard montiel
ouais les gars je regarde à la télé quoi
ouais c'est parce que ce soit à le voir
en vrai nom héros c'est le gars non
lesquels h bal à 60,60 way et bottega
lâche toi je m'engage je m'imagine pas
d'elle on s'en fout et il a 60 ans
bernard mottais convaincre anniversaire
10 9 avril chez 1h57 donc ça fait 60 ans
donc non vous saurez vaut 60 ans non 61
mais on n'a pas terminé vous avez fait
du genre et vous sûrement à saint barth
d'ailleurs away à johnny si vous les
normes et ouais mais nous on est comment
ce qu'on n'était pas invité ça fait loin
il y avait qui doit vite et surtout
c'est vrai personne qu'en dit on et
quelques invités à votre anniversaire on
le fout dans la mer des amis de
différentes régions
merci à julie ville et à des coûts
[Musique]
on dit qu'on a découvert sur ok c'est ma
web vous arrête de arrête avec tes
clichés sur scène passe pas que du tout
mais j'adore qui faisait alors un bon
ado fm absolument oui yahya yahya un peu
de tout mais il ya beaucoup de succès
j'adorerais zoukeur doux mais chaque
camp pour pouvoir sauver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]